C'est vraiment dur comme travail.
Les mules, c'est nous.
C’est un enfer.
Ici, c’est un enfer.
Ici, on travaille dur.
Nous, les femmes, nous faisons
vraiment un travail exténuant.
Aujourd'hui,
on a gagné 1,50€.
C'est ici que je mourrais.
Ça fait 20 jours
qu'il n'y a pas de poisson.
Tout ce que je veux,
c'est que mes enfants
aient une vie meilleure.
C'est incroyable,
mais Maréco et son frère
trouvent encore de quoi se nourrir
au fond de la boue.
Au centre de la fange,
la boue est encore assez liquide
pour que des milliers de poissons-chats
arrivent à survivre.
Les poissons-chats sont tellement nombreux
qu'on ne peut pas les compter.
On fait ça pour gagner
de l'argent pour mes enfants.
Si tu ne vas pas dans le lac,
tu ne mangeras rien.
Il faut lutter pour manger.
C'est un combat
entre les poissons et nous.
C'est un travail acharné
que Dieu nous a donné.
C'est dur.
C'est fatiguant d'utiliser cette lance.
J'ai mal aux épaules.
Et j'ai vraiment froid dans la boue.
En ce moment, je suis engourdi de partout.
J'ai faim.
J'ai soif.
Ça m'épuise.
Mais pour cette vache,
il y a encore un petit espoir.
Maréco va tenter de la sauver.
Il en a perdu plusieurs dans la boue.
Quand on ne les surveille pas,
nos bêtes partent
dans tous les sens.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir
dans la vie ?
Est-ce qu'on aura
encore des vaches ?
“Vas-y tire ! Tire !”
“Stop !”
“Elle est encore vivante,
elle va se lever.”
Un miracle.
Les petites mains qui travaillaient
dans les plantations
balafrent la terre
à la recherche du filon
qui les sortira de la misère.
Pour descendre,
il faut attraper le piquet.
Il faut vérifier qu’ils sont bien solides.
Tu mets ton pied et tu descends.
15 mètres plus bas,
le risque est permanent.
Mais qu'importe.
Entre mourir de faim en cultivant du cacao
ou devenir riche en affrontant le danger,
le choix est vite fait.
Pour des hommes
comme Romaric.
Ça, c’est le coffrage.
Il peut s’effondrer à n’importe quel moment
et nous pouvons tous mourir.
La première étape,
c’est d’enlever toute la boue.
Pour trouver la roche.
L’or est enfermé dans ces pierres.
Celles qui en contiennent le plus
se trouvent encore plus profondes.
Vers 20 mètres.
Vous trouvez beaucoup d’or ici ?
Pas assez !
On en trouve un peu
mais pas beaucoup.
Il y en a peu,
mais toujours assez pour rêver.
Romaric refuse de trimer
toute sa vie dans la plantation familiale.
Avant, j’étais étudiant.
Mes parents n’avaient pas les moyens
de payer mes études.
Quand j’ai arrêté les études,
il n’y avait pas de travail.
J’ai été obligé de venir ici.
La Côté d’Ivoire est un pays émergent,
mais la jeunesse souffre.
Mon rêve est de trouver un filon d’or,
gagner de l’argent,
et retourner dans mon village.
Puis de construire une belle famille,
de mettre mes enfants l’école,
et vivre sur la terre de mes ancêtres.
C’est ici que je suis né,
c’est ici que je veux mourir.
En surface, les cailloux sont broyés,
puis tamisés.
J’ai 6 ans.
Je travaille ici pour me payer
mes fournitures de classe.
C'est un enfer.
Ici, c'est un enfer.
On travaille dur...
Et on ne gagne quasiment rien.
On a juste de quoi se nourrir,
c’est tout.
Nous, les femmes,
nous faisons vraiment
un travail exténuant.
Ici, les tâches les plus pénibles,
et bien, ce sont les femmes
qui se les coltinent.
On a marché dans la montagne
pendant 1h et demie pour arriver ici.
Là, je prépare mon chargement
pour retourner au village.
Il nous faudra encore 1h
et demie de marche.
Nous coupons l'herbe durant l'été
et le reste de l'année, nous venons
en chercher un peu chaque jour.
Chaque ballot pèse entre 20 et 30 kilos.
Si malgré mon âge je continue
à travailler aussi dur,
c’est pour une unique raison
que mes enfants puissent
avoir le choix d'une autre vie.
Dérisoire funambule,
dont la vie ne tient
qu'à un fil.
Une rafale de vent
un peu forte,
et le pont peut
se retourner
Pour éviter trop de prise au vent,
les hommes n'ont posé
qu'une latte sur deux.
Gare aux étourdis !
Elles auront mis 5h
pour faire l'aller-retour
jusqu'au village.
Pour remonter des palourdes,
je peux rester 3 minutes sous l’eau.
Je m’occupe des 3 rayons :
du fruits et légumes, du poisson
et de la boucherie.
Donc il faut être partout,
Ça fait partie de notre job.
Le mal de dos,
il est là.
On va mettre les palourdes au feu
et les faire bouillir.
Vraiment un travail de malade.
et on est en bas de l'échelle.
Regarde là ! Regarde !
Des milliers de chauves-souris
sont accrochées à la voûte.
Boots et Solji ne les chassent pas,
elles sont précieuses.
C'est grâce à leurs déjections
qu'ils gagnent leur vie.
Le problème, c'est lorsqu'elle
lâche une crotte sur toi.
C'est vraiment pas très drôle,
mais on a fini par s'y habituer.
C'est comme un grain de sable
qui te tombe dessus.
C'est un peu froid et mouillé.
Les mammifères volants
défèquent dans la grotte
depuis des centaines d'années.
Et leurs excréments est un super engrais.
C’est un bon fertilisant pour les choux,
les tomates, les poivrons.
C'est vraiment bien.
Il n'y a pas de produits
chimiques, c'est naturel.
Quand il creuse,
Boots n'est jamais très rassuré.
Je n'ai pas peur des chauves-souris.
Je veux juste ne pas être mordu
ça peut être grave.
Mon médecin a dit que ça peut
empoisonner ton corps,
donc évite qu'elles t’approchent.
Tu sais, tu peux attraper la rage,
donc je garde la lumière près de moi.
Comme ça,
les chauve-souris restent à l'écart.
Au fond de la grotte
on manque d'oxygène,
on respire très mal.
Parfois,
je suis obligé de m'arrêter et sortir
une bonne demi-heure
pour reprendre une bouffée d'air.
Je ne veux pas m'évanouir dans ce trou,
Moi, ce que je crains,
ce sont les attaques de serpents.
Certains sont agressifs,
vicieux,
et ils te mordent.
Depuis mes 21 ans, je fais ça.
Donc ça ne date pas d'hier.
Et maintenant j'ai 55 ans,
donc ça fait 34 ans
que je travaille dans cette grotte.
Ce boulot, je ne veux pas que
mes enfants le fassent.
Trop dur pour eux.
Je dis ça de tout mon cœur.
Tout ce que je veux,
c'est que mes enfants
aient une vie meilleure.
Ce sac de terre,
ils le vendent 10€.
Une belle somme en Jamaïque,
où le salaire moyen
ne dépasse pas les 350€.
Abou est une victime de la route.
Fauché par une voiture dans sa jeunesse.
L'idée de mendier lui était insupportable.
Alors, malgré sa jambe paralysée,
il s'est donné une mission.
Un jour, je me suis levé
et j’ai dit à mes frères
que ces voies créaient
beaucoup d’accidents.
Alors pour remédier à cela,
je me suis dit que je devais
essayer d’aider nos frères.
C’est pourquoi je me suis
engagé sur la route.
Inlassablement,
il rebouche 1 à 1
tous les nids de poule.
Je suis là sept jours sur sept.
J’ai déjà réparé 70 km de route.
Par jour,
grâce à ceux qui ont pitié de moi,
je peux gagner entre 2 et 3 euros.
Compte tenu de ma situation, je ne peux pas
dire que ce n’est pas beaucoup.
Mais j’ai une femme et 2 enfants...
Je suis très fatigué.
Son courage sauve des vies.
Grâce à lui, les trous disparaissent,
et camions, voitures et motos
ralentissent toute la journée.
Pour le remercier
d'entretenir la route.
Sur la route,
des petites mains essaient de gagner de
quoi manger en réparant la piste défoncée.
Hé ! Venez ici !
C’est pour vous trois, c’est compris ?
Toi, tu es le plus grand.
Tu le partages bien en trois !
Toi, lui et l’autre aussi.
Merci monsieur.
Vous partagez le billet en trois, hein !
Ils ont bien réparé la route.
Ils ont bien travaillé.
Aujourd'hui, on a gagné 1,50€.
J'ai arrêté l'école
après le CE1
parce que ma famille est pauvre.
Je suis venu ici pour travailler
au garage.
Moi,
je veux apprendre le métier.
Je veux tout savoir
et devenir comme le maître.
Le garagiste emploie 7 enfants
et 3 ados
qu'il rémunère
comme bon lui semble.
C'est pas facile de gagner de quoi manger.
Je touche entre 8 et 20€ par jour.
Si je gagne beaucoup,
je leur donne beaucoup.
Si je gagne peu,
je leur donne peu.
Parce que je m'occupe aussi
de ma mère, de ma femme, de mon fils
Voilà comment je sors le sel de la terre.
Je découpe des morceaux dans le sol.
Je sors la plaque de l'eau salée,
je la nettoie et après je la vend
au tailleur.
Les forçats du sel
gagnent 2€ par jour.
Tout juste de quoi survivre.
Moi, je suis le plus ancien.
Ça fait 18 ans que je fais ce métier.
J'ai 6 enfants à nourrir et pour ça,
je travaille tous les jours dans le désert.
Ici, tu payes pour manger, pour te loger.
En fait, tu payes pour tout
et pour toute ta famille.
Du coup, je n'arrête jamais de travailler.
Certains jours, la température frôle
les 50 degrés à l'ombre.
Seul problème il n'y a pas d'ombre.
Il fait très chaud, le soleil nous brûle
et le sel nous ronge les yeux,
la peau des mains et des pieds.
Chacun se rafraîchit avant d'entamer
les 3 jours de marche du retour.
Avec mes 30 chameaux,
je transporte 200 kilos de sel.
Je vais marcher pendant 3 nuits
pour aller le vendre en ville.
Ces inlassables travailleurs,
équipés d'outils dérisoires,
sont des centaines à s’exténuer
sur les routes
pour 5€ par jour,
sans aucune protection.
C'est un métier très fatigant.
Ça fait 3 ans que je fais
les chantiers.
Pour cela, je dois me lever très tôt
On casse des pierres
pour l'entretien des routes.
On doit tout acheter,
même notre nourriture.
Les ouvriers rentrent en Inde
tous les six mois.
En attendant,
ils vivent dans ces baraques de fortune.
Regardez, c'est ici qu'on dort.
On est 10 à dormir
dans la même pièce.
Au total, on est 14.
Les autres dorment à côté.
La vie est très difficile ici.
Le patron exige qu'on travaille beaucoup.
Les problèmes,
ce sont les pluies torrentielles.
Il y a des rats partout.
Et si on veut acheter de la viande,
il n'y en a pas.
On doit survivre tous les jours avec
des pommes de terre et des aubergines.
Pour faire face à
une future catastrophe,
le village se fortifie
en érigeant des digues.
Partout ailleurs, ce sont les mules
qui transportent les charges.
Mais à Limi, les mules, c'est nous.
Tout le monde est logé à la même enseigne.
Les jeunes comme les vieux.
Même le maire met la main à la pâte.
Il pourrait nous regarder travailler.
Mais ça ne se passe pas comme ça ici.
On est une communauté.
Tout le monde est réquisitionné
car l'aide de l'Etat est très faible.
On n'abandonnera pas notre village.
Les glissements de terrains
et les inondations emportent nos maisons
et les terres que l'on cultive.
Mais on est né ici.
On ne peut pas partir.
Beaucoup de personnes
nous disent :
Pourquoi vivez vous
dans un endroit aussi risqué ?
Pourquoi ne pas aller ailleurs ?
Nous resterons ici.
Il nous est impossible de quitter
la terre de nos ancêtres.
Ils sont les seuls à être acceptés
par le peuple de la nuit.
Les hyènes.
Au début, quand je voyais
les hyènes, j'avais la trouille.
Je m’enfuyais en courant.
La hyène est très forte.
Si jamais elle mord,
vous n'avez aucune chance.
Une seule hyène a la force de 7 chevaux.
Heureusement, on peut savoir
quand elle se sentent menacées.
Elles émettent de drôles de cris.
Je leur donne à manger tous les soirs
parce que sinon, elles restent sauvages.
Depuis le XIXᵉ siècle,
un pacte unit
les hyènes aux habitants d'Harar.
Comme son père,
Malugeta leur rapporte à manger
toutes les nuits depuis 26 ans.
La confiance est totale.
Regarde dans ce trou.
Il y a plusieurs bébés.
Dès qu'il y a un bruit,
ils se cachent immédiatement,
Regarde, voilà la mère.
Malugeta se fait un peu d'argent
en revendant de temps en temps
les bébés à des zoos.
Je n'arrêterai jamais de donner
à manger aux hyènes.
Jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
je ferais ce métier.
Je suis chargé de la sécurité des vaches.
Si des bandits arrivent pour nous les
voler, je leur tire dessus immédiatement.
Le lait est trop précieux pour nous.
On ne peut pas se permettre
de perdre une vache.
Combien elles coûtent ?
Ça peut valoir entre 400 et 500€.
On est là pour les défendre
jusqu'à la mort s'il le faut.
C'est le seul moment où je les abandonnerais.
Il faut dire que chez les Mundari
le nombre et la beauté des bovins
conditionnent la richesse d'un clan,
le statut social d'un homme
et le prestige de toute une famille.
Tu te laves comme ça tous les matins ?
Oui, tous les jours.
Je repère facilement
une vache qui va uriner.
Quand elle est allongée et qu'elle se
lève, c'est qu'elle va faire pipi.
C'est vraiment bon pour toi ?
Oui, ça renforce mes cheveux,
ça les décolore aussi.
Mais l'urine sert surtout d’antiseptique
pour désinfecter la peau.
Et toi reste là, gros lard
Lui, il a vraiment une tête de vache.
C’est le cas de le dire.
C'est rare que je l'appelle
Fêtard.
Fêtard, c'est quand on me
demande son prénom.
Sinon, c'est Titi, Bonhomme, Vieux...
Puis le gros aussi, puisqu'il est gros.
“Allez, bonhomme là !”
Antoine a un rêve avec Fêtard,
décrocher le titre du taureau
le plus lourd du monde,
au Salon de l'Agriculture.
C’est l'objectif.
Battre le record du monde.
- Grogne pas,
tu vas l’énerver.
- Il va s’abîmer.
- Calme, calme !
Allez !
Tu te fais du mal là.
Ça y est pépère.
Et l'autre il a peur, il a peur.
- Détache-le
Maintenant il a peur de l’autre,
il n'a qu'une envie,
c'est de se barrer
parce qu'il a peur.
J’ai pas envie qu'il se fasse du mal.
Allez, viens Loulou, viens !
Viens là !
Avance encore.
1950 !
- C'est que du bonheur.
- Pourquoi ?
- C'est le plus lourd du monde.
C'est délicat avec cette charrette,
si elle se renverse, je perds la récolte.
Les feuilles peuvent se casser.
Il faut y aller avec précaution.
Effectivement,
les cigares les plus réputés
sont fabriqués
avec cinq feuilles de tabac entières.
Elles ne doivent comporter
aucune déchirure.
Le temps est mauvais
et il va pleuvoir.
Il faut protéger le tabac.
Si le tabac se mouille, c'est un problème,
il perd sa qualité.
Je pourrais les recouvrir
mais je n'ai pas de bâche.
C’est une des fiertés, c'est vrai
qu'on est content de l'avoir.
Et nos clients aussi l’aiment bien.
Puis, ça ajoute
le folklore également.
Ça fait deux ans qu'on l'avait pas sorti.
On est vraiment contents
de le sortir enfin,
lui autant que nous.
8h25,
on ouvre dans 25 minutes,
Tout le monde va le voir,
c'est sympa.
Et si avec ça on n’est pas dans
le Pays Basque,
je sais pas où on est.
27,10 dollars
Hé, salut Chucho !
Je t’apporte des fromages.
C’est très bien.
Mets-les par ici.
À El Viento,
l'argent ne coule pas à flots
et le peu que les gens gagnent
se dévalue tous les jours
à cause de l'hyperinflation.
En clair, l'argent ne vaut plus rien.
Alors Chucho a remis le troc
au goût du jour.
Les paysans apportent du fromage
ou du café,
et je les échange contre
les produits de l'épicerie.
C'est comme ça que je me paye.
Ici l'argent, on ne connaît pas.
Notre gouvernement a fait n'importe quoi.
La monnaie nationale ne circule plus.
En une semaine,
le prix d'un kilo de pommes de terre
peut être multiplié par 4, voire 10.
Ça fait maintenant dix ans
qu'on vit dans une situation de crise.
Tout n'a fait qu'empirer.
Les gens s'habituent à survivre
de cette façon,
mais ça reste très difficile.
Bonjour !
Que Dieu vous bénisse !
Ce sont mes trois filles.
Quand Chucho descends en ville
vendre ses fromages,
c'est Lorena, la plus grande,
qui passe derrière la caisse.
Afin qu'elle ne manque de rien,
je fais des sacrifices pour mes filles.
Je risque ma vie sur la piste.
Elle compte plus
que tout pour moi.
Lorena n'est jamais rassurée
de voir partir son père.
Mais Chucho n'a pas le choix.
En quinze jours, il a déjà échangé
pour 700 kilos de fromage.
Il faut les vendre
avant qu'ils ne s'abîment.
Au revoir, fais bonne route,
je t’aime fort
Comme quasiment
à chaque fois,
la deuxième voiture du village
l'accompagne.
Personne ne roule seul sur cette piste.
Cette partie est très compliquée
à passer.
C'est une vraie galère.
Ça ressemble à un sentier pour les mules.
Ce rocher-là,
il est bien solide.
Il ne m'a jamais lâché.
Il est bien accroché à la falaise,
il ne bouge pas.
Il est costaud comme un taureau.
Fort comme un éléphant.
60 mètres de descente
sans aucune sécurité.
Enfin, si
un petit échauffement.
Je fais ça pour augmenter la force
dans mes bras.
- Elle est solide, cette corde ?
- Oui !
- Elle a combien d'années ?
- Elle a dix ans.
Écoute la mer comme elle résonne.
Elle a une belle voix.
Elle m'a dit surtout ne t'en vas
pas, reste,
tu vas faire une bonne pêche.
Chicoca est peut-être le seul pêcheur
alpiniste au monde.
Ici, il y a eu trois morts.
Ils ont lâché.
Ils ont eu des crampes.
Ils ne se sont pas échauffés
comme moi avant de descendre.
Alors pourquoi prend-il
autant de risques ?
En fait,
cet endroit est une réserve naturelle.
Le poisson abonde.
La pêche au filet est interdite.
Seule la ligne est tolérée.
Chicoca ne souffre donc
d'aucune concurrence
ou presque.
En moyenne,
le pêcheur remonte
près de 20 kilos de poisson
par jour.
Mais aujourd'hui,
rien ne mord.
Eh oui, ces amis les otaries ont fait fuir
une partie du poisson
et la houle a fait le reste.
Les poissons sont partis au large,
la mer est trop forte,
il n'y a rien à pêcher.
À 66 ans, l'exercice
devient à chaque fois plus difficile.
Chicoca passe plusieurs semaines
dans le désert.
L'homme n'a pas les moyens
de gaspiller de l'essence
pour rentrer chez lui
tous les soirs,
à 35 km de là.
Je me repose pour demain.
Demain, il faut de nouveau aller pêcher.
Ce sont des appâts à plumes de coq.
C'est moi qui les fabrique.
Ça fait 20 jours
qu'il n'y a pas de poissons.
Je vais rester 30 jours de plus
avant de rentrer
pour pouvoir
ramener du poisson à ma famille.
C'est ça la vie d'un pêcheur.
Ça, c'est une ancienne combinaison
des employés du pétrole.
C'est facile à trouver.
On l'échange contre du poisson.
C'est la seule chose qui reste
de l'entreprise.
Son nom.
J'ai fabriqué ces rames
avec deux couvercles de pots de peinture.
J'ai percé le plastique
et je les ai vissés au bâton.
Aujourd'hui, je ne gagne pas assez
pour utiliser mon moteur
ou acheter un meilleur bateau.
José n'a pas d'essence,
mais il a des idées.
C'est comme revenir des siècles
en arrière
ils naviguaient comme ça,
au temps des pirates.
Il y a de moins en moins de poissons.
Avant, on faisait des bonnes pêches,
mais maintenant c'est fini.
Il faut aller de plus en plus loin
et travailler très dur
pour attraper quelques poissons.
Je suis né et j'ai grandi sur ce lac.
Les enfants sont nés ici, ils grandissent
ici et c'est ici que je mourrais.
Les fuites de pétrole ont commencé
il y a 6 ou 7 ans
et le gouvernement ne fait rien
pour les colmater.
Ça ne ressemble plus du
tout au lac de mon enfance.
Le mien était propre et sans pollution.
Je n'aurais jamais imaginé
que mes enfants allaient vivre ça un jour.
Les récupérateurs ont pris possession
de toute une partie de la ville.
Tout ce qu'ils ont glané
dans les poubelles,
ils le revendent ici.
Ils redonnent vie à tout ce qui est cassé.
Le moindre bout de métal
devient un objet utile.
Ici, personne n'a les moyens
d'avoir une machine à découper l'acier.
Tout se fait à la main, à la confiance.
Personne n'a le choix.
Ce commerce nous permet
de nourrir toute la famille.
Ici, on se connaît tous.
On est comme une grande famille
et on dépend tous
de ces petits boulots.
On se transmet le savoir-faire
de génération en génération.
Ces artistes façonnent
des pelles en métal recyclé, bien sûr.
Ça coûte combien de faire
un barbecue avec ça ?
Donne-m’en pour 1 euro.
Nous on va le revendre 2€.
On est nombreux sur ce marché
à vendre ce genre de brasero
Mais on arrive à faire de bonnes affaires.
Si je travaille bien, j'arrive
à en fabriquer quinze par jour.
Je travaille tout ce qui est en métal.
Je fais des cheminées,
des pots d'échappement et des gouttières.
C'est mon travail, il me nourrit bien.
Dans un magasin,
ce brasero coûterait beaucoup plus cher.
En 20 minutes,
les deux plaques d'ordinateurs
sont devenues un mini barbecue.
On est pas privilégié là ?
Pas un bruit, pas de klaxons.
Personne qui nous embête.
Voilà, c'est le paradis, là.
Avec un temps pareil,
aujourd'hui, c'est le paradis.